(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- Hi, I'm Alexandra Billings,
and I'll be reading an
excerpt from my upcoming book,
This Time for Me.
Early one morning, as the
sun streaked across the tile
of our newly laid kitchen floor,
I sat cross-legged in one of
Mimi's long green dresses,
barefoot, and eating my Frosted Flakes
directly from the box,
looking out into our backyard.
I had only put on lipstick
that morning, no other makeup.
I was six and had been dressing
up for a while by then.
It seemed a part of me.
I felt better.
I was happy.
My feet clicked as I wobbled
back and forth on the floor.
My long dress covering my knees
and my lipstick smearing a bit
as the flakes spilled out onto my lap
and stuck to my cheeks.
I began to hum We've Only Just Begun,
which was my theme song.
I was humming,
playing with a beam of
light in the early morning,
and picking up random flakes
from both my lap and our
spotless kitchen floor.
I had found my joy.
As Mimi turned the corner
from the dining room into the kitchen,
I felt my heart race.
I knew the mess on the floor
and on me might set her off.
I began to clean up as quickly as I could.
I was singing a song she loved
and I hoped she might wanna join me.
She'd never really heard me sing.
And I was having such a good time
I thought she might
want to come and join me
for my Karen Carpenter
Frosted Flakes party.
She stopped as I turned towards her,
my back to the sliding glass doors.
Her face dropped and
her eyes began to lower.
I thought at first
she was staring at the
crumbs on the floor,
and then I realized she
was staring at the dress.
Her head began to shake. Her
mouth turned downward a little.
And I felt my insides begin to churn
as if I had eaten bad cheese.
She didn't speak or move.
And then in a whisper,
she said methodically
and with great emphasis,
"Don't ever wear that again."
I held my breath.
"Scott,
do you understand me?" she asked.
Her eyes flashed black
and her finger pointed
at my borrowed gown.
From all of us to all of you
with great love and many blessings,
Happy Transgender Awareness Week.
Thank you.
(upbeat music and applause)